well I for one find most of those online
ads very annoying but maybe I'm just not
enough a big data savvy let's talk to
someone who is Daniel domscheit-berg
he's a computer scientist and many of
you will know him as the former
spokesman of WikiLeaks thank you very
much for being here with us today I
learned you don't have a mobile phone
why is that first of all I don't like
the pace of modern society so I'm trying
to retreat a little bit from that and on
the other hand I don't like to be
profiled and I don't want people to know
too easily Who am I talk to or who my
meeting with okay so how much of an open
book
are we already we average Internet users
and smartphone users I think we're all
pretty much open anyways having a mobile
phone and not doesn't really make too
much of a difference but we're all using
electronic communication we're shopping
online and all of these things and all
this data is being collected and people
are building profiles and at the end of
the day the scary part is that they
really know which book you would want to
read the next time I'm just trying to
imagine I mean there's millions and
millions of people on this planet and
they're all using a smartphone and the
internet and all this data is being
collected collected that must be huge I
mean can they actually look at it all
not really
right now this is I think the biggest
challenge in this whole part is that
it's a challenge and how to use big data
and it's the biggest gold rush that is
possible for anyone trying to develop a
really good method of data mining all of
this these vast amounts but it's not
like nobody has an incentive and a lot
of people are putting a lot of money in
there so it's just a matter of time and
computing power
for example businesses obviously they
they wanted to know as we just see in
the report what kind of shoes I might
want to buy or not want to buy but can
an algorithm really find out how I take
well I think to a certain extent it can
but this is also where part of the
problem lies and this is where the
biggest problem of surveillance lies is
that an algorithm is really very
imprecise and it's classifying us it's
putting us into a certain shell for some
way it's it's categorizing us or
whatever and at the end of the day I
think it's not so precise that
it does reality justice but interesting
that you would say our next report is
going in that direction just a quick
question are you going to shop in
yourself yeah okay then stay around this
might interest you and I'll have more
questions for you what has Big Data got
to do with my choice of coffee or tomato
ketchup a lot because anyone who wants
to sell something wants to know what
appeals to customers now the eye
tracking systems developed by the
Brandenberg company send so motoric
instruments makes it possible the
devices look a bit like freaky reading
glasses and they show what catches the
eyes of whoever is wearing them for
example a customer in a supermarket in
the Czech capital Prague